The joe rogan experience?
No,
I don't eat database by friend Ross.
Broccoli is this comedian is a great name.
Yeah,
he's just really look this up.
If you can't get away carrot top and make a salad shell back.
Is there another vegetable guy?
Uh
hmm.
I,
well,
they call me.
They accidentally a at the Faneuil hall comedy connection.
A black woman called the club and she say,
who on the show tonight?
She was from,
she was from the 18 hundreds and a and they said,
well as Anthony Clark,
Jackie Flynn and Greg Fitzsimmons and a lady goes,
ease grapefruit Simmons,
the headliner.
That's a great name.
Call me grapefruits in is to this day all the comics in Boston coming
grapefruit,
grapefruit Simmons,
she's changed my name.
That's a great name.
Like emo Phillips.
I know that's not his real name.
It doesn't offend me.
Carrot top this on his real name.
Either Fruit Simmons.
Right,
but look up Ross,
Broccoli and a and chicken truck.
Maybe you could go out from here on out as grape Simmons,
grapefruit Simmons,
the artist formerly known as Greg Fitzsimmons.
I need something for people to talk about it.
That's,
that's the kind of shit that's brilliant marketing.
If you're into that kind of thing.
Right.
Just change your name every 15 years and have people,
you know,
I have to get the Twitter account,
change everything.
Grapefruit Simmons.
Well that's one of the ways that Madonna sorta stayed relevant all these years
is constantly changing.
Right.
She changed what she looked like.
She changed her hairstyle.
She changed her singing style,
but always in intervals that allow the public to,
you know,
adjust.
Yeah.
David Bowie did the same thing to say.
You can use pot actively or passively know.
You could fuck up with anything,
man.
That's what I think.
I think it's grapefruit summons.
It's a cover of your next scene.
Great.
Whoever made that,
who made that give it,
give them some prompts.
Falling ardor maybe falling ardor yeah,
it's all that.
I've told that story before and yeah,
I found a couple of fans send me artwork.
Oh,
that's lovely.
Great.
One up on the wall in my office.
One.
That's the one that's on the wall.
My office.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
that's so fun.
That's a good one too.
Cause it looks like your face that's got sort of a,
that's really similar.
Rawling at a fair.
That is really funny.
So yeah,
I need,
I need a new brand.
That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to change the grapefruit Semans
okay.